we are in the middle of this innovation
economy we do two things in universities
if you really boil it down we're in the
education business and we're in the
research and innovation business when it
comes to education we train the next
generation we recruit we retain we
develop the next generation the kind of
people were training our people in
cybersecurity in robotics in software
engineering and so on and so on and
these are exactly the areas that we're
seeing significant job growth the second
aspect that has to do with our research
and innovation how do we how do we
contribute to this innovation economy
well it's through the startups that come
out of these universities it's also
creating a entrepreneurial environment
where entrepreneurs and innovators want
to come to Pittsburgh and be here over
the last five to seven years we've had
about 140 startups that have come out of
CMU directly or indirectly we have
accounted for about a billion dollars
worth of venture investment and
follow-on investment in these companies
about 70% of that has gone to companies
that are still in Pittsburgh and there
are still in our region if you look at
what's happening globally we are at the
center of a societal and economic
transformation that's taking place it's
enabled because of advances we're seeing
in automation advances we're seeing in
digitization of information and also
advances that we're seeing in in
unprecedented access to data and
analytics folks if you step back and
look at this these are exactly the areas
including robotics autonomous systems
and so on these are exactly the areas
that Pittsburgh and our universities
have invested in these are the areas
that are transforming every sector of
our economy from healthcare as Jeff
would to attest to that to
transportation to energy distribution to
planning future cities not to mention
our business impact education is being
transformed as a result of access to
technology the indirect facility that
sits in Lawrenceville today just imagine
20 years ago that facility was put
together now notice what has happened 20
years later
it has helped catalyze that environment
it's not a coincident that we have 35
robotics companies that have popped up
all over the city especially in
Lawrenceville and in Strip District it's
not a coincident that through some
really judicious investment that we have
seen such a growth in East Liberty and
also in bakery square where Google and
Autodesk and all of them are are
positioned there I think you have an
amazing alignment of public sector
private sector our civic institutions
obviously foundations and companies and
the universities and so on we're all
doing amazingly well we're all
contributing to this economy without any
doubt what I think is a big game changer
for us is we need to have a way where we
are much much more nimble in responding
to opportunities that show up
opportunities come our way and we need
to have ways were much better organized
to go leverage it and build on it I'm
personally very excited about this